- 'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'e
est devenue un lien vital
avavec le reste du pays.
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s st
la guerre ou ceux qui
chchoisissent de rentrer chez e.
chez elle à, Kiev.
"Je veux vraiment rentrer
chez mnununununununununununununn
et de mon chat."
Au quai voisin, un train
entre en gare, mais ce train
Des bénévoles de Médecins
sans frontières se dépêchentC'Ci
en hôpital, se prépare à quitter
pour une mission de trois jours.
des malades et des blessés.
Dr JEAN-CLÉMENT CABROL, médecin
- C'est aménagé pour pouvoir
mettre un peu de matériel
ou autre. À l'entrée,
on a un petit poste de santé
avec plus de matériel. Et sinon,
à chaque fois. Un, deux.
- Les couchettes de cet
ancien train de nuit ont été
transformées en lits d'h
partout comme ça.s s s s crochex
servent à suspendre des sacs
de perfusions et une génératric.
- La semaine dernière,
sur le premier voyage,
c'était que des
Donc, c'était pratiquement
trois familles qui é
prises dans les bombardements
de Marioupol avec des familles
décimées, avec des
- Le train s'apprête à aller
de patients et les ramener ici,
à Lviv. Unee e e e e soulager
les hôpitaux débordés
de l'est de l'Ukraine.
Un long trajet de 24 heures
qui serait presque imp
par la route.
À bord, un médecin urgentiste,
un pédiatre, un anesthésiste
et des travailleurs humanitaires
dévoués.
KAREN DESMIDT, travailleuse
humanitaire, MSF
"On a fait maintenant
une évacuation. Etoioioioiois
les réactions des patients
qu'on ramène, quand même,
ça fait bien au coeur, quoi."
- Des moments touchants,
mais aussi d'autres déchirants.
- La semaine dernière,
il y a un enfant qu'on n'a pas
pu prendre. Il était en choc
septique et il était trop
instable pour pouvoir faire
24 heures de train."
rererererere train sera bientôt
aménagé avec de l'équipement
spécialisé pour transporter
les cas les plus graves,
des patients en état critique.
La destination est gardée
secrète pour des raisons de
sécurité. S'approcher des zones
de combat sqsqsqsqsqsqué.
"Je sais que ça peut être
dangereux, dit cette jeune
infirmière ukrainienne de
23 ans, mais c'est tellement
important d'aider nos citoyens."
(klaxon de train)
Dans un pays où le réseau
ferroviaire résiste toujours
aux horreurs de la guerre,
l'opération est aussi
essentielle que symbolique.
Une locomotive imposante
et imperturbable, à l'image
de la résilience des Ukrainiens.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Lvi